ah
[Música]
lo han llamado el oro blanco de américa
latina' muchos gobiernos han vendido la
idea de la explotación de litio como uno
de los artífices de un posible milagro
económico pero a un alto precio dejando
a su paso un daño irreparable para el
medio ambiente el más reciente país en
lanzarse a la búsqueda del litio es
méxico una carrera incierta a la que
muchos dicen ya llega un poco tarde pero
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador sigue en su línea de
estatizar los recursos del país tal
parece que son lo que busca así lo
evidencian por lo menos sus acciones
sólo dos días después de no haber
conseguido poner en marcha o haber
puesto en marcha tras la apertura del
sector eléctrico consiguió un triunfo en
el parlamento al ser aprobada una
reforma minera dicha reforma gira en
torno al litio en su exploración y
también su explotación
ahora entendidas como un aspecto de
utilidad pública por lo que será creada
una entidad pública en el gobierno
mexicano para que maneje esta gestión
de acuerdo con la información del
servicio geológico mexicano este país
cuenta con cerca de 82 puntos
comprobados con manifestaciones de litio
en al menos 18 estados de la república
mexicana siendo el desértico estado de
sonora el que tiene la mayor cantidad de
puntos le siguen puebla y oaxaca
para el año 2019 encuentran también allí
en mexico en el estado de sonora el que
es considerado como uno de los
yacimientos de minerales más grandes del
mundo se estima que tiene un total de
243 ocho millones de toneladas de
minerales entre ellos litio y es un
yacimiento que se estima tenga una vida
útil de unos diecinueve años de acuerdo
con investigaciones del servicio
geológico de eeuu el suelo mexicano
tendría un total de 17 millones de
toneladas de reservas de litio pero que
es el litio exactamente es un elemento
metálico químicamente reactivo y es el
metal más ligero en cuanto a peso y
tiene un bajo punto de fusión con otros
metales por eso su unión por ejemplo con
el magnesio sirve para la industria del
blindaje o con el aluminio es utilizado
en la fabricación de aviones y de trenes
de alta velocidad está presente en al
menos en 145 especies minerales que
tienen presencia de litio y puede ser
encontrado en pozos petroleros en campos
geotérmicos en arcillas como es el caso
mexicano ya está en el océano
para qué se utiliza pues se utiliza
mayormente para la elaboración de
baterías recargables para teléfonos
móviles para nuestras computadoras
portátiles para las cámaras y para los
vehículos también también son utilizados
para la fabricación de baterías no
recargables como por ejemplo para
aparatos como por ejemplo un marcapasos
para los relojes o para juguetes es
ampliamente usado también en la cerámica
y en la fabricación de vidrio también de
grasas lubricantes en procesos de fusión
como ya les explicaba en producción de
polímeros y hasta en la fabricación de
aires acondicionados para la
purificación del aire
llega a mexico tarde a esta a este bus
de la extracción del litio que se ha
dado en el continente americano que se
puede aprender de otros casos en el
continente como por ejemplo el de
bolivia el de chile o el de argentina es
el litio entonces ese oro blanco del
siglo 21 para méxico o simplemente es
otra de esas larga historia de bonanzas
que ha tenido américa latina como la que
no consiguieron llegar a buen puerto
como por ejemplo la bonanza cafetera la
avena la bonanza del cobre o la del
petróleo incluso la de la soja entre
tantas que podemos nombrar a lo largo de
la historia de nuestra región hoy en el
debate de france 24 analizamos el tema y
para ello saludamos entonces a la
doctora aleida azamar alonso ella es
coordinadora de la maestría en
sociedades sustentables de la
universidad autónoma metropolitana y
también es presidenta de la sociedad
mesoamericana y del caribe de economía
ecológica ya se conecta desde la ciudad
de mexico la capital de la república
mexicana y desde la paz bolivia se
conecta a juan carlos zuleta él es
analista de la economía del litio cuenta
con cerca de tres décadas de experiencia
industria minera ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden hacer parte
de este debate o de este análisis mejor
con todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas ya lo saben pueden escribir a
través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24 bajo ese
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos entonces todos sus comentarios
y preguntas para este análisis comienzo
entonces con la doctora aleida asa madre
la ciudad de mexico preguntándole por
ese potencial real que tiene méxico y la
región centroamericana o latinoamericana
en este caso si tiene información al
respecto pero principalmente en el caso
mexicano cuál es el verdadero potencial
es esto real o estos son
digamos unos espejismos que vende el
gobierno mexicano para tratar de poner
en marcha una industria que puede
traerle algunos beneficios económicos
pero que no pueda ser sustentable en el
largo plazo
muchísimas gracias buenas tardes a ti y
al público igual a nuestro colega
invitado es un gusto poder estar aquí
respondo a tu pregunta no que de hecho
está también en pantalla no que si es el
oro blanco el litio es uno de los 20
minerales señalados justo por el banco
mundial para poder realizar una
transición energética a futuro este
metal como ya tour bien lo comentabas no
tiene aplicaciones variadas pero en
cuestiones de tecnología sustentable son
muy limitadas se aplica principalmente
para la creación de baterías de larga
duración pero en el que estamos hablando
principalmente principalmente de
vehículos maquinaria y otras tecnologías
a pesar de que tiene otros usos
industriales la relevancia que ha tenido
elite en los últimos años desde mi punto
de vista es solamente especulación y
probable probablemente en dos décadas
deje de ser tan importante esto no
significa que vaya a dejar de ser
utilizado pero hay otros recursos que en
el largo plazo pueden competir y
reemplazar al litio como cuáles las
baterías de sodio que están comenzando
ya a mostrar avances pues muy
importantes entonces esto es como para
que quede claro no que el litio no es un
recurso que va a mantener su alto valor
agregado en largo plazo que tampoco es
el oro blanco esto sería un error y
haremos de esta forma entonces justo
compararlo con el oro o con el petróleo
es lo que genera mayor especulación y
termine enriqueciendo pues a las
empresas están obtienen también mayores
ingresos principalmente hasta el momento
por cotizar en la bolsa de valores y un
ejemplo muy claro pues justo lo tenemos
estos impactos limitados o bien
comentados de otros países no en el caso
de china y argentina que llevan casi
tres décadas extrayéndolo su industria
de extracción es limitada para lo que va
el bienestar digamos del país socio
ambiental o para los ingresos o para los
impuestos no representa una parte
importante es más bien marginal justo a
pesar de los grandes niveles de
inversión y producción que tiene
entonces bueno no significa que no voy a
tener utilidad su aprovechamiento pero
pues no es la panacea que nos va a sacar
de pobres y creo que como ejemplo pues
no según lo mirará bolivia que en el
caso de bolivia que además nacionalizó y
ya están pensando antes de que fuera el
golpe de estado en un mural es ya se
comentaba que se iba invitar a empresas
tanto privadas nacionales y extranjeras
para ayudar a extraer el litio porque
ellos no han podido extraer entonces ahí
me queda le para dar el panorama y
podemos seguir gracias
bueno pues doctora aleida gracias por
estar aquí en el programa le doy la
bienvenida también entonces a juan
carlos zuleta en la ciudad de la paz
precisamente conoce en detalle el caso
boliviano que es uno de los casos más
llamativos en la región en américa
latina' por el proceso que tuvo y lo que
ha representado para ese país hasta el
momento
juan carlos bienvenido al programa
gracias por acompañarnos y el comienzo
preguntándole por la experiencia
boliviana que tanto ha beneficiado a ese
país la extracción del litio y qué
lecciones puede aprender méxico que
también ha nacionalizado este mineral y
que va a empezar a extraerlo a gran
escala en diferentes puntos ya lo
mencionaba yo cerca de 82 puntos a lo
largo y ancho de la república mexicana
qué experiencias puede tener méxico en
cuenta que ya vivió y transito bolivia
sí bueno buenas tardes muchas gracias
por la entrevista en principio quisiera
referirme a algunas palabras vertidas
por la persona que me antecedió en el
uso de la palabra
con relación al tema del mercado con
importante es el litio
en barca
el mercado en general y para el mundo
para el mundo en la economía mundial
lo que quisiera decir es que el litio se
ha convertido efectivamente en mineral
crítico en mineral estratégico
porque una de sus principales
aplicaciones tienen que ver
con el uso del litio en baterías
recargables para vehículos eléctricos
como todos sabemos la industria
automotriz
constituye una de las industrias más
importantes del mundo
y en los últimos años se ha empezado a
dar un proceso de transformación en esa
industria automotriz porque se ha
introducido
el fenómeno de la de la electromovilidad
sucede que la mayor parte de los países
industrializados que practican entre
todos tienen fechas tope para modificar
sus matrices energéticas y en particular
para avanzar hacia la electromovilidad
esto ha convertido al litio en como
verde como os decía anteriormente en un
mineral estratégico
en cuanto a la experiencia boliviana en
esta materia
e
quisiera comentar que como llegará si de
día se anticipó la industria del litio
está completamente estatizada en bolivia
desde
[Música]
2010 prácticamente que disculpándose
lanzó latín
si era
y yo
en la explotación en la extracción y
procesamiento del litio son
completamente estatales y dejando
solamente la última fase del
aprovechamiento e industrialización del
litio es decir la transformación de
materias primas refinadas en bienes
diferentes es decir la industrialización
propiamente dicha y abierta a la
participación de empresas extranjeras
claro
doctora aleida le preguntó por el caso
mexicano es un caso que vimos hace unas
semanas este proceso de la
nacionalización y la aprobación en el
parlamento mexicano
de llevar a cabo esta explotación que
panorama entonces tiene méxico para
poder extraer el litio va a hacerlo como
lo intentó hacer bolivia a desarrollar
su propia tecnología cosa que no pudo
lograr y luego tuvo que en acceder a
empresas extranjeras para terminar de
complementar su proceso de tecnificación
para completar los procesos o van a
aliarse con empresas extranjeras con
empresas chinas que se han mostrado muy
interesadas en explotar los yacimientos
mexicanos cuál es el panorama que tiene
nadie
ok bueno dos cosas ya lo mejor
diferentes no una vale la pena resaltar
justo en el caso de méxico las
fortalezas que tenemos respecto al litio
el creo que eso es importante porque
sabemos que el 30 por ciento de nuestro
territorio ha sido explorado no es justo
para minería esto implica que existe un
enorme potencial para poder encontrar
pues grandes depósitos de distintos
recursos minerales
el litio justo en el depósito de sonora
fue descubierto por accidente justo
cuando se estaba buscando boro en la
concesión donde ahora mismo está
bacanora litio entonces esto implica que
incluso el espacio ya explorado podría
revisarse con las nuevas técnicas que ya
está haciendo el servicio geológico
mexicano que tú bien comentaba es el año
pasado para revaluar estos 88 depósitos
de litio conocidos en el país para
verificar la viabilidad pero que podría
saber más o con mayor capacidad y además
de destacar este potencial territorial
que tenemos nosotros también vale la
pena destacar la situación geográfica
del país porque en donde se encuentra
por lo menos el gran depósito del
proyecto de señora de litio que se sabe
no está muy cerca del puerto de guaymas
con un alto volumen de exportaciones
hacia asia no la región más importante
en cuanto a producción de baterías y
otros recursos que se derivan del
líquido también algo importante que
tenemos que contemplar es justo pues la
cercanía con estados unidos de hecho
justo ya se hablaba no de la plata de
automóviles eléctricos una parte de la
extracción de sonora litio que
probablemente se pronostica para sacarse
a finales de 2022 inicios de 2023 está
comprometida justo con esta sigue la
fábrica este es la no igual otra otra
cuestión que deberíamos de contemplar es
que justo la minería ha sido un oficio
histórico para gran parte de familias y
grandes empresas mexicanas que han
vivido siempre pues aprovechándose de
los recursos entonces cuestiones
normativas que son importantes el marco
normativo y la regulación fiscal juegan
a favor de todas las empresas ahora
ahora mismo no pues igual comentamos que
justo la ley minera permite en las
concesiones son por 50 años con
prórrogas 50 años más entonces esto pues
atrae muchas inversiones extranjeras no
y que además lo que se invierte es
mínimo en comparación justo con los
beneficios que se obtiene y el marco
fiscal también pueda un buen esquema
digamos para estas empresas porque es
muy lazo generalmente el sector minero
en años anteriores cuando más ha pagado
ha pagado 0.52 por ciento de impuestos y
ha podido deducir muchísimos impuestos
en inversión social en deducciones en
otras cosas entonces esto es decir
pueden tener un gran beneficio las
empresas puede ser una gran afectación
social y socio ambiental vale la pena
destacar lo no igual todo el agua que se
va a utilizar pero justo preguntamos en
cuestión de la ley a mí me parece que
hay dos puntos que podrían ser a favor
de esta ley y tres o cuatro puntos que
podrían ser en contra a favor el primero
que podemos decir es que nos damos
cuenta que la ley minera si se puede
modificar eso es muy bueno a quienes
llevamos años intentando justo que se
modifique la ley sobre todo por la
cuestión de utilidad pública el tiempo
que tienen para las concesiones 50 años
con 50 más que justo se transparente la
información fiscal etcétera entonces
bueno ya nos dimos cuenta que si se
puede modificar esto es positivo otra
cuestión positiva es justo lo que tú
comentaba que se está hablando de que
pertenezca a justo a la nación eso es
algo muy bueno estamos hablando que los
recursos sean justo para méxico eso es
positivo no pero lo negativo yo
respetaría cinco cosas negativo es que
tenemos una rigidez normativa que no
está considerando las limitaciones
técnicas y económicas que tenemos no
somos capaces nosotros en este momento a
nivel nacional desde el gobierno no
digamos desde una empresa que se crearía
mexicana y poder extraer justo a litio
ni procesar nada de esto de hecho se ha
dicho que para que se pueda desarrollar
un buen proyecto no nos llevaría entre
una y dos décadas si es a nivel digamos
estatal 2 está reforma mantiene algo que
es muy perjudicial que es de la reforma
previa la utilidad pública esto es grave
porque significa que la minería del
sector minero está por arriba
prácticamente de todos excepto
hidrocarburos y energía y significa que
si justo una persona tiene su cosecha de
arroz frijol maíz etcétera pues y hay
minería la minería está por encima de
eso significa actividad pública igual
ganados está por encima de la soberanía
alimentaria soberanía
hídrica no y cualquier otro tipo de
derechos igual me parece que otra
cuestión negativa de esta reforma es que
no están claros los marcos de trabajo a
qué me refiero todavía no se ha definido
con claridad cuál va a ser el organismo
de que va a trabajar el organismo
turístico para litio qué va a hacer cómo
lo va a hacer esto no está definido y
otra cuestión que me parece negativa es
que hemos estado sobre estimando la
relevancia que tiene el ite en realidad
por eso está tan alto en la bolsa de
valores pero no tiene tanta relevancia
después me parece que eso es muy
importante comentarlo para tener
claridad tanto en la reforma que se
propuso en otras cuales serían como lo
positivo lo negativo como también en
estos puntos no de cuestiones que
tenemos como ventajas pero también
desventajas sobre la contaminación en el
agua que se puede utilizar las
cuestiones culturales económicas
sociales interiores doctora asha mar
justo eso son parte de los puntos que
vamos a analizar más adelante a lo largo
de este programa los tengo acá en la
agenda en la relación con las
comunidades y el tema medioambiental
quiero preguntarle a juan carlos en la
ciudad de la paz en bolivia
por el caso que conoce obviamente de su
país de bolivia que es un país que llamó
mucho la atención
por esta nacionalización bajo el
gobierno de evo morales porque no es
considera un caso de éxito el caso
boliviano que ha fallado
al fallar muchas cosas en primer lugar
la industria del litio se desarrolló en
bolivia
tratándose de una industria
prácticamente nueva si bien bolivia ya
tenía más de 400 años de experiencia en
minería
no tenía experiencia en este tipo de
minería es una minería distinta se trata
de una minería a partir de salmueras las
salmueras vienen a ser
yacimientos mineralógicos que se
encuentran en una especie de aguas de
sal
[Música]
con minerales muy concentrados en esas
aguas y esta experiencia
digamos era nula y en su momento cuando
el año 2008 el gobierno de evo morales
inició las
actividades de desarrollo de la
industria de litio en bolivia
a raíz de esto el país no contaba ni con
la tecnología ni con recursos humanos
necesarios
adicionalmente el proyecto fue
encomendado a un grupo de técnicos y sin
ninguna experiencia en minería
y sobre todo con prácticamente un
conocimiento nulo sobre el mercado
mundial del litio
y todo esto concluyó en una situación de
virtual fracaso en el proyecto del litio
en la medida en que luego de 14 años de
trabajo
y alrededor de 800 millones de dólares
invertidos o gastados
en los resultados
se ven por sí mismos el país apenas pudo
obtener una producción de alrededor de
500 toneladas
métricas de carbonato de litio
por año
esto esto es totalmente insuficiente es
un resultado insatisfactorio
si se compara con la producción mundial
de litio año pasado que fue de alrededor
de 532 mil toneladas de carbón perdón sí
de carbonato de litio y equivalente
entonces todo esto refleja una situación
d
desaciertos enormes desaciertos por el
gobierno de evo morales inicialmente y
continuados por los siguientes gobiernos
en la medida en que hasta ahora no ha
podido haber no se han podido reflejar
mayores avances en la industria litio en
bolivia claro
entendible el punto juan carlos allí en
la ciudad de la paz en bolivia
doctora asha mar no quiero entrar en
temas muy políticos lo que nos reúne
para esta conversación es nos lleva a
hablar sobre la extracción de esta
industria que quieren comenzar allí en
mexico pero no puedo dejar de
preguntarles sobre el plan que tiene el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
en cuanto a los recursos mexicanos hizo
un intento por llevar a cabo una reforma
energética que le permitía al estado
prácticamente controlar todas las
fuentes de energía del país eso espantó
un poco también a la inversión
extranjera que quería desarrollar allí o
estaba desarrollando algunos proyectos
nuevos de energías renovables como ve
usted este proceso de estatizar la
minería el litio los recursos naturales
del país todo esto pensando en el
beneficio de los mismos mexicanos
como punto de partida para para esta
respuesta
gracias por no hacerlo quito ya
comentaba como dos puntos que haya
positivos y cuatro que vayan negativos
pero me parece importante no justo
comentar qué pasa con esta reforma qué
es lo que estamos preguntando gracias
por la pregunta bueno hace ratito ya o
se comenta comentábamos no que el litio
pues es un metal que se ha considerado
estratégico justo principalmente desde
el punto de vista por la especulación
que se ha hecho entonces esto también ha
llevado a que se eleve la demanda y el
costo del mismo mineral pero beneficio
unos pocos entonces el presidente con la
reforma eléctrica pues buscaba
principalmente atajar dos temas a la vez
uno de ellos fortalece a esta capacidad
nacional de producción eléctrica no
dotando justo a la comisión federal de
electricidad a la cfn de cierta ventaja
sobre sus competidores para evitar
situaciones como las que ocurre en
europa donde los mecanismos del mercado
privado han generado costos nunca vistos
y también pues la otra que se buscaba el
otro punto pues era justo garantizar el
litio para que fuera utilizado pues
únicamente por connacionales en esta
reforma justo es importante decir como
bien lo comentaba aunque se incorpora al
litio con un mineral estratégico y que
no puede ser concesionado
se carece de definiciones de precisiones
especialmente en los minerales que
acompañan al litio porque hay otros
minerales nunca completan litio como
decíamos el bolso dio otros que han sido
también de clavos estratégicos como un
contaban en níquel entre otros entonces
todos estos que se supone que van a
ayudar a la supuesta transición
energética entonces se esperaba que en
este caso ya cuando fue aprobada la
reforma pues si hubieran también
expedido como lineamientos secundarios
que profundizarán en todos estos
aspectos sea como sea va a ser por qué
minerales etcétera no pero bueno esto se
dejó justo al arbitrio de pues el
ejecutivo o no el congreso de hecho
entonces de esto también ya lo
observamos en la ley minera de 1992 se
están usurpando responsabilidades que
constitucionalmente le compete nada más
al congreso pero se puede dejar usted ya
se dijo secretaría de economía
secretaria energía etcétera no desde la
energía como los minerales entonces el
litio no en este sentido me parece que
se está considerando como también se
dijo el nuevo petróleo que dada la
importancia que está cobrando sobre todo
por la retórica presidencial y bueno
también será importante y en los dos
años al pasado y en palabras del
presidente lo que él decía es que no
había dinero
proyectos que aprovecharán este mineral
por lo cual se necesitaba la
participación de actores privados
entonces en las idas y venidas no tanto
de las declaraciones del presidente como
de la secretaría de energía racional
el litio acabó convirtiéndose pues en un
mineral justo fundamental este para la
soberanía energética pero no queda claro
por qué ya que su función principal
justo en este tema pues es la
elaboración de materias de alta
capacidad como estás líneas ha comentado
juan carlos no entonces no es relevante
para nuestro sistema de producción
tampoco para la distribución eléctrica
me parece que se sobrestimó y aquí ya
valdría la pena tener rescatar otra cosa
ya nos hablaba en algún mundo también
con carlos algo de las materias de litio
para poder producir baterías de litio se
necesitan cinco etapas y estas cinco
etapas es importante igual las mencionó
rápidamente no la primera justo es la
minera o sale la prospección la
exploración en la extracción el
desarrollo tendrá todo lo que lleva la
minería la segunda etapa es el
refinamiento la tercera son los
electroquímicos la cuarta son las celdas
la quinta son los ensamblajes de
baterías y vale la pena decirme que en
el caso de chile y argentina son
nuestros únicos países de américa latina
que participan en la primera etapa y
chile en la segunda ya ni siquiera
bolivia
y brasil que también tiene el litio y
que principalmente se en salmuera sino
en arcilla participan entonces la
pregunta que nos podríamos hacer y que
valdría la pena es en qué etapa o cómo y
dónde va a participar méxico cuando
además no tenemos arcillas no tenemos la
capacidad ni tecnológica ni económica ni
de inversión para poder sacar entonces y
lo dejaría justo para dejó sobre la mesa
doctora ese tema de la extracción de la
arcilla que es un caso muy particular al
que se va a enfrentar méxico porque esto
implica un proceso distinto o un poco
más engorroso digámoslo así y también
genera un poco de incertidumbre por el
daño ambiental que esto puede generar
precisamente porque la extracción en
arcilla es mucho más complicada juan
carlos en el caso boliviano ya vimos que
las ganancias y las utilidades que puede
haber dejado la extracción a lo largo de
estos años no ha sido tan espectacular
como muchos pensaron que podría ser allí
en bolivia las comunidades cercanas a
los yacimientos de litio en bolivia
recibieron algún beneficio transformaron
su forma de vida cambiaron empeoraron
cómo fue la relación con ellos
a ver qué bueno en realidad no se puede
decir que el quelite ha obtenido mayores
efectos en la economía boliviana porque
el litio en sí mismo no ha sido
completamente desarrollado o sea no es
el caso de chile por ejemplo donde yacen
empezaba a percibir una serie de
defectos medioambientales sobre las
comunidades que habitan en los lugares
circundantes a los solares o al salar de
atacama en particular no es el caso en
bolivia porque como les decía
el desarrollo de la
industria del litio es todavía
insuficientes está en una etapa muy
incipiente ahora
[Música]
se verá más adelante cuando
digamos bolivia empieza a producir al
menos 30 mil toneladas no es cierto de
carbonato de litio equivalente si estos
efectos medioambientales podrían
ocasionar algunos problemas sobre todo
en las comunidades locales circundantes
al salar de uyuni
pero quisiera además comentar algunos
puntos que fueron vertidos por
la persona que me acompaña en el debate
en ella menciona que el tema de litio es
especulativo yo discrepo con ella
absolutamente en ese tema yo vengo
siguiendo este asunto desde hace cerca
de 30 años y tengo claridad respecto al
comportamiento del mercado los usos del
litio y como estos han ido evolucionando
a través del tiempo no creo que sea
especulativo una manera
sí es cierto que se hablan de muchas
cosas en torno al litio pero
si lo que ha sucedido
en los últimos meses último año en
particular el respecto al precio
estiramos un tema de especulación me
parece que es eso una idea equivocada
porque lo que ha sucedido es que
básicamente el precio se ha multiplicado
por 25 y 6 veces
debido principalmente a la demanda eso
no es ninguna especulación además no
está ahí nadie esté especulando una
lista ocultando litio para elevar el
precio en lo que sucede es que como
mencionaba al inicio de mi conversación
la mayoría prácticamente todos los
países industrializados han decidido
usar el litio con un mineral estratégico
para transformar la industria automotriz
global y se han puesto fechas tope para
hacer esa transformación que es la green
ha empezado a tener efecto en la demanda
porque prácticamente todas las
fábricas de vehículos están
incorporándose en la electromovilidad
entonces señores no es especulación de
ninguna manera
quiero comentar un tema más sobre las
baterías de sodio que también haya
comentado ha dicho que el psoe podría
sustituir a limpias es decir no tiene
mucho fundamento es decir yo soy uno de
los
iniciadores precisamente en los temas de
discusión sobre las las posibilidades de
las baterías de sodio y estoy consciente
de que si el sodio podría sustituir pero
particularmente en uno en uno de los
usos en un tipo especial de baterías que
son las baterías del fp no más allá de
las baterías lfp es poco probable que el
sodio pueda sustituir al litio en
baterías recargadas para vehículos
eléctricos claro
respecto al tema de la electricidad
el litio en las baterías de élite
también pueden intervenir en los temas
de generación y distribución
particularmente en generación porque se
pueden acoplar a sistemas de generación
de electricidad a través de energías
renovables las baterías pueden acoplarse
a esos sistemas y de esta forma
participar en los procesos de generación
de energía en los temas de distribución
de la misma forma las baterías
y recargables de litio pueden ser
acoplados a sistemas de distribución
energía eléctrica clara precisamente
estabilizar la red eléctrica
todos estos usos no son conocidos por
por muchos porque son temas nuevos son
muy especializados son técnicos claro
porque yo conozco bien estos temas y por
eso quería comentar estas cosas claro
que es importante esa aclaración juan
carlos en doctora asha mar en ciudad de
méxico quiero hacerle la misma pregunta
que le hacía a juan carlos en torno al
tema de las comunidades y el tema
medioambiental méxico ya es un país que
tiene experiencia en la extracción
minera en la industria petrolera y tiene
cerca de 15 mil conflictos ambientales
por temas de minería y por temas de
extracción es una cifra bastante alta
que se discute allí en torno al tema
medioambiental y al tema de la relación
con las comunidades donde están cerca
los yacimientos también teniendo en
cuenta que muchos de estos yacimientos
están en zonas donde hay escasez de agua
en partes que son desérticas en el norte
de méxico algunas de ellas
y esto también puede dificultar un poco
la abstracción
sí muchísimas gracias por la pregunta se
considera no en muchos momentos que el
impacto socioambiental es técnicamente
menor a otros proyectos similares de
minería pero es importante decir que
para la extracción de litio se requieren
más de dos mil toneladas de químicos
para procesos productivos además justo
por cada tonelada de litio y por cada
tonelada de las sales de litio no se
evaporan dos millones de litros de agua
la cual no solamente es escasa como bien
lo decías no en donde se encuentra el
litio sobre todo en el proyecto de
sonora pero también en otros casos al
mismo en a4 etcétera pero también es
importante decir que contaminan los
depósitos subterráneos justo del agua y
me parece que es importante considerar
varios impactos como bien preguntabas
voy a comentar algunos en el caso
ambiental aparte de que ya dijimos que
puede contaminar no y me parece que hay
varios aspectos que se pueden dar uno de
ellos es la transformación territorial
que va a afectar justo a las especies
locales debido al desmonte y a la
creación de estructuras necesarias para
el proyecto para cualquier proyecto
minero en este caso también vale la pena
decir que tan solo en la concesión de
bacadéhuachi no en sonora se ocupan 100
mil hectáreas con posibilidad de crecer
esto es equivalente al tamaño de una
pequeña ciudad si lo contrastamos con el
nuevo aeropuerto la ciudad de mexico en
santa lucia
este último utiliza solamente cuatro mil
500 hectáreas y estamos hablando de 100
mil hectáreas para el crédito de
bacadéhuachi entonces y ya justo este
aeropuerto ya representa un enorme
riesgo socio ambiental entonces no todo
el espacio donde está la mina se ocupa o
se modifica pero para la concesión está
sujeta no a que tenga pues impactos y
transformaciones en caso de considerarse
necesario porque pues es la concesión
por todo el territorio y todas las
hectáreas que les dieron estas
modificaciones también realmente en el
espacio de vida silvestre no las
especies locales van a notar que les es
imposible justo llegar a sus lugares de
descanso y alimentación entonces aunque
esto no impide su tránsito de forma
digamos tan directa se imposibilita que
puedan caminar por muchas zonas que ya
se conocían sobre el impacto hídrico que
me parece muy importante que sería el
segundo punto que tocaría justo se
requieren cantidades masivas de agua
para la extracción y en este caso como
bien lo decía si estamos hablando de
arcillas entonces en los espacios donde
existen humedad por lo menos en varias
partes de américa latina no son altos
lugares que tienen un alto estrés
hídrico entonces esto también será
preocupante sobre todo en el caso de
méxico ya hay estudios que justo
comentan que la cantidad necesaria para
la extracción
en chile es de más de 600 litros de agua
por minuto sólo por poner un ejemplo
nosotros como personas y ciudad de
méjico que consumimos bastante
consumimos 300 litros de agua diarios y
está en la minería de litio serían 600
litros por ser por minuto nosotros vale
la pena rescatable me parece que es una
cantidad escandalosa para mantener este
balance ecológico otras cosas que me
preguntabas que también parecen muy
importantes es justo todos los esfuerzos
productivos mineros no son exentos no
están exentos de accidentes o de
derrames derrames de combustibles
destrucción de bombas de extracción
generación de escombros no heridos
problemas con el territorio la falta de
pericia de los trabajadores la seguridad
eficiente entonces este punto está me
parece que es importante destacarlo y en
la cuestión social qué bien me
preguntabas no y aquí hay un montón de
cosas que se tienen que analizar pero
voy a intentar en un asumirlo la primera
de ellas es que justo cuando una empresa
llega y se instala contrata a poca gente
del lugar generalmente necesita muchos
especialistas entonces contrata digamos
para la apertura de la mina para la
extracción de desechos para el
transporte de materias primas pero como
se conforme se va especializando el
proyecto y va haciendo más grande se
necesita justo a personas más
especializadas no se reduce la cantidad
de trabajadores se busca personal
especializado solamente por decir en
méxico sólo hay 300.000 empleos para
trabajadores en la minería entonces ahí
podemos medir equivale al 1 por ciento
entonces ahí nos damos cuenta que esto
no ayuda otra cosa que me parece
importante de esta acción el doctor es
que no se fomentan procesos de
sostenibilidad en el largo plazo no se
crean cadenas productivas en el lugar no
se impulsa el desarrollo comunitario
entonces por el contrario se está
privatizando el territorio se compite
con la industria local que suele ser
agrícola social turística se
imposibilita justo pero el largo plazo
no soy bitkom por los riesgos que tiene
la minería que se puedes cambiar eso
también provoca la contaminación otros
problemas doctor podemos hablar de otros
proyectos mineros que la doctora me
queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa y necesito que ustedes haga una
conclusión por favor muy puntual sólo
tengo minuto juan carlos su perspectiva
a su conclusión de esta situación que
vive méxico
un poco espejo a lo que vivió bolivia su
conclusión
sí bueno en principio no hay minería no
contaminante no es cierto y como bien
dice la doctora hay que avanzar hacia
procesos de generación de valor y ese es
el gran desafío a diferencia de bolivia
y otros países en sudamérica méxico
tiene una enorme oportunidad al frente a
través de el desarrollo de su industria
del litio porque además está muy cerca
del principal mercado
económico del mundo seamos unidos y
canadá entonces yo creo que debería
aprovechar esa oportunidad
y no dejar para después un tema que
podría ser muy beneficioso para atrás
como mi doctora su conclusión es
rápidamente baja carlos acosta no porque
me quedan pocos segundos el doctor a su
conclusión
muchísimas gracias yo creo que se tiene
que volver a revisar justo en la
industria del sector minero
principalmente para el litio porque si
pensamos que va a ser estratégico aunque
sea por poco tiempo todos los daños
sociales y ambientales que provoca si
deja ganancias económicas pero aquí a
los empresarios y en este caso sería el
gobierno el gobierno pasaría a jugar el
papel que ha jugado en los empresarios
estamos violentando derechos de las
comunidades indígenas el convenio 169 de
la oit el artículo 4 de la constitución
entonces yo llamaría a que se hiciera
una revisión más profunda que no fuera
de utilidad pública y que se revisara lo
que sucedía en otros casos doctor con
contaminación e impacto social es
muchísimo sabéis los invitados del día
de hoy les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros ustedes pueden seguir con
france 24
[Música]